let's go back to that breaking news
story that explosion in West Jerusalem
Alan Fisher joins us on the phone now
from there Alan what more details can
you tell us
well what we've found out is that there
have been two explosions the first was
at a bus stop in West Jerusalem now
according to Israeli Army Radio the the
explosion was caused by a device that
was planted near a motorcycle
in that incident we are told that there
have been 10 casualties and two of the
Wounded uh critically injured obviously
on their way to hospital at this stage
there has been a second explosion at a
place called Rama Junction again in
Western Jerusalem at the moment there
are no reports of of injuries around
there but they're expecting that to
change what we are being told and what
we can see from the pictures is that
there is debris over a wide area now
this is surprising it has been several
years since we've seen bomb attacks in
West Jerusalem tensions have been high
on the West Bank and in East Jerusalem
over the last few months because hours
of is really Army operations but what we
do know is that this is certainly an
escalation in what has been happening
yes there have been a number of stabbing
attacks we've seen that over the last
several years but it has been at some
considerable time since we've reported
on explosions in West Jerusalem a number
of political leaders say they're on
their way to the scene including those
who are currently involved in
discussions to join a coalition
government under Benjamin Netanyahu they
will obviously make statements at the
scene one of them is the man who would
like to become the new police Minister
uh and he has said that it's time for
the country to get its act in order so
that clearly shows that there is going
to be a political escalation after what
we've seen in West Jerusalem in the last
hour or so all right Alan Fisher life
was there in West Jerusalem Alan thank
you for that